headspace it's a very popular meditation
app that aims to bring mindfulness to
the masses the app provides guided
meditations - it's nearly 30 million
users first on CBS this morning the
company is announcing headspace health
it's a new division that hopes to launch
the first prescription meditation app
headspace co-founder Andy put a comb and
chief science officer Megan Jones Bell
join us at the table
sorry I almost forgot that good more
than both of you Andy you started this
in 2012 why why now it does there need
to be a prescription for this so I think
on the sides pointing Megan Megan can
talk best to it but I do think he's
reflective of how we think about mental
health I think he's changed enormously
over over the past decade I think in the
past meditation was maybe seen more as a
lifestyle kind of choice whereas now
we're actually starting to see a shift
so towards us more sort of clinical lens
enough making if you wanted to I mean
one of the things that we found in our
research is that meditation can impact
both mental and physical health in a
pretty profound way the American Heart
Association recommends meditation for
heart disease and so what we've shown
what we found in our research has led us
to the formation of headspace health
because we know there can be both mental
and physical health benefits this is not
anecdotal this is scientific evidence of
this right exactly and there are results
that show that it worked
you know lately I've noticed doctors are
saying to me do you meditate and that's
only recently that I think that they're
actually bringing the question up and
there are a lot of people that I think
you'd be surprised at the number of
people who meditate Andy but yet there's
still a lot of closet meditators and
don't want to say I do it why yeah do
you think that is so I think it if to
say that we meditate normally normally
implies that sometimes we struggle with
with our mind right and the truth is
it's just part of the human condition
blank life is difficult yeah and we all
need a way to cope with it and the
exciting thing for me over the years has
been and we talked a little bit right
off-camera just kind of how you know
headspace is about 5050 in terms of many
women can it who use it and I think
that's a real kind of shift in the past
it was maybe seen as something that
women would do and and with it being on
the phone man I think often feel like
actually there's something private
can do they don't need to necessarily
discuss with anybody or tell anyone they
can they can stand to still be
vulnerable yeah maybe not kind of tell
people and the fact that it's on the
phone you should break it down because I
think the graphics are so welcoming and
friendly yeah I mean and you you have it
divided in categories that's what I
think is so great different meditations
for different things that are going on
for instance so I think that the the
most popular for since we began asleep
stress anxiety I think more recently
grief has being kind of a really popular
one on the app productivity and as we've
started to partner waves we partner with
the NBA and with Nike and start doing
more sports stuff as well we've started
to see a lot more popularity in those
those paints and Megan connect the
what's the app with the science in other
words the amount of time you have to
spend the number of days people know the
relationship between them because it
does seem daunting to John it seems
daunting oh gosh how do i how do I find
the time to do well that's something
that's really unique about the research
that we're doing at headspace because
it's on our actual product and so what
we show is that using our product which
is typically in studies about 10 minutes
a day we see an effect after 10 days we
see an effect after 30 days how do you
measure the effect what is it using
typical psychological measures of
perceived stress of sleep all of our
current studies include much more robust
measures where we're you know actually
measuring blood samples of cortisol were
we're using connected devices so we've
moved into much more rigorous multi-site
really high-caliber research so that we
can both advance our understanding but
advanced the science around meditation
and as a clinical psychologist explain
what this FDA approval why you want that
sort of approval what it would do well
it's important because what we're going
to be developing with headspace health
is clinically validated content so it's
going to be a separate product that's
developed in collaboration with patients
physicians patient advocacy groups and
it will be designed as a prevention and
treatment intervention which means that
it really should be done under the
doctor's supervision and that's why FDA
clearance is necess
that's just so interesting you could
actually have you know we get
prescriptions for pills you get
prescriptions for lots of things we
don't get prescriptions for like
mindfulness or to go to a nap for
something and that could completely
transform ya technology I think it can't
it to be clear like I don't I think it's
amazing but we shouldn't wait to get to
a point where the doctor needs to
prescribe it yeah I'm a big fan of kind
of preventative rather than treatment so
if we if we have the opportunity and the
inclination I would strongly advise
people whatever they use kind of to
learn meditation and users are
preventative well we don't want to say
whatever they use we want them to use
headspace I think of you and even sort
of that Oprah Winfrey of meditation and
I say this because Oprah's the only
Oprah's the only covergirl that we've
had at Oprah Magazine you are the voice
of headspace do you see that changing or
you just do you have the attitude if it
ain't broke don't fix it well because
your voice is very soothing I leave up
to the rest of the team to make those
decisions I think as we go international
so at the moment we're going through the
process of translating yeah and there's
no way that I can know that quickly so
we're starting to test now and see kind
of how other other voice is performing
in other territories right now the race
is good nice to see nice to meet you
guys thank you I think Kenny and Megan
great to have you here thank you so much